on a un problème en france simple le
salaire en général net est trop bas et
le salaire brut est trop élevé c'est à
dire que le salaire que touche les gens
est trop bas et le salaire brut le paye
les patrons est trop élevé et donc
évidemment quand on augmente le smic on
augmente le salaire brut aussi et c'est
déplorable pour la compétition souligné
il ya la question des charges sur les
indices actuellement sans en payer un
salaire de 1 euro le patron ça lui coûte
3500 euros alors justement vous avez une
mesure qui était annoncé qu'ils aient la
baisse de la csg je vais être un peu
technique c'est oublier dames c'est la
ville économie 1 c'est la baisse de la
csg sur les salaires jusqu'à 2000 euros
le problème c'est que la cg c'est pas
une cotisation un exam ours et un impôt
est que si vous baissez la cotisation
pour ce type de salaire il faut la bc
pour tous les français c'est
constitutionnel alors une nuance si vous
me permettez
effectivement vous faites référence à
une décision du conseil national en 2000
ou 2001 c'était le gouvernement jospin
qui avait voulu déjà baissé et la csg
pour les sept salaires et le conseil
cautionner lui avait dit ça je pense
désormais que les temps ont changé je
vous expliquer pourquoi en deux mots le
pas être trop technique pas trop mauvais
télé jean mais depuis le prélèvement à
la source oui et le prélèvement à la
source permet de connaître les revenus
des uns et des autres et donc on peut
ajuster ok donc je pense en cinq sets a
rappelé que le conçoit la maintenant je
pense que c'est plus de vent je reviens
aussi sur une mesure vous avez annoncé
que vous avez un peu de ça permettra
quand même un treizième mois pour les
smicards alors est-ce que les gens
m'aiment beaucoup on sait combien elles
ont quand même beaucoup assure une
mesure vous avez annoncé déjà et que
vous avez un peu développés tout à
l'heure qui est cette idée de supprimer
les fameux frais de notaire pour les
jeunes primo accédants qui achètent un
appartement jusqu'à 250 mille euros mais
est ce que vous pensez qu'aujourd'hui
les jeunes 1 son nom des situations
financières économiques suffisantes pour
avoir à se dire en fait le premier truc
que j'ai envie et que je peux faire
c'est m'acheter un appartement un an ou
alors c'est de finir les fins de mois
non mais il ya des jeunes
yat-sen et jeunes tous les jeunes ne
sont pas dans la précarité il ya ça n'a
pas été des points quel âge en plus pour
la 18 ans et pas comme qu'on a 25 ans
quand on a 28 ans donc ça c'était pour
une mesure de jeunes un peu installé et
qui ont du mal à s'acheter un
appartement voyez ce n'est pas pour les
mines deuxièmement il ya d'autres
mesures pour le pouvoir d'achat j'ai
proposé aussi l'extension de la
participation vous connaissez le système
de la participation évidemment la donne
a changé par le général de gaulle en 59
rendu obligatoire 67 avec un plafond de
posséder 100 salariés et ce seuil a été
abaissé à 50 moi je propose de la bca
salariés pour permettre aux enfants ou
aux salariés des petites entreprises
doivent bénéficier et deuxièmement
pardonnez moi vraiment une sortie du jeu
propose aussi la défiscalisation et la
simplification parce qu'aujourd'hui la
plupart des gens qui ont la
participation de la touche pas parce que
c'est trop compliqué parce qu'il ya trop
de contraintes etc et donc ça fera une
augmentation vraiment majeur de pouvoir
d'achat vous avez bien compris la
logique j'essaye de trouver des moyens
qui augmente le pouvoir d'achat des gens
sans
l'alourdir la compétitivé sens en a
empiété sur la compétitivité des
entreprises